any man who marries a woman past the age
of 23 years old you're getting leftovers
but uh yeah David listen man
um I'm not trying to be mean-spirited
but you married a single mom like
post-wall women they get married all the
time but the men they get married to are
very low value they're beta males
they're pushovers they're not real men
they're not the men that arouse these
women so credit for credits do uh this
man makes fun of other people's spouses
and different things like that claims
you would never date a single mom well
somebody pulled up his girlfriend's
bankruptcy records because those are
public records that anyone has access to
and they found some interesting
information let's see listen and I'll
give credit to the people involved I'll
link the videos and below so there you
go Devin is one of just a few women I've
dated older women I've dated who didn't
have any kids when I met them but again
they're the exceptions um Devin is my
girlfriend she is not my wife we have
never been married she is not a single
mother and we do we have not adopted
anybody I got a 13 year old niece that
stays here at least twice a week because
Olivia she's 14 years old now and she's
dude she's a beautiful girl she could
and so as we now look at her application
on the screen and go to the section
describing her household it states
do you have dependents
yes does the pendant live with you yes
dependent's age
10 years old
dependence relationship to debtor 1.
daughter
I want to make something clear I don't
care what kind of woman you choose to be
your girl be with who you want to be you
want to date a single month then he said
I don't care what I don't like and what
I think is very laughable is you run a
course you have video clips making fun
of other men for dating single moms and
criticizing those women now keep in mind
that this also contradicts everything
Donovan sharp has taught his audience
about the types of women to avoid going
all the way back to his days when he
wrote for Return Of Kings to his free
ebook called 16 ways to immediately
disqualify her for a relationship where
he states that single mothers should be
avoided as they make for the worst
girlfriends wives and mothers I was a
single Bob and yes listen I know single
moms are Badness and that and the other
but we all got to start somewhere
welcome don't commit to him you've been
married before okay you've been married
before I got married young and I was
married for a very long time
[Music]
you know for the 20 something years
before we met you know as an as an adult
I met you when you were 32. uh you are
an older woman Devin my girlfriend is an
older woman okay yes my girlfriend is an
older woman she turned she turned 36
back in February I misled my audience
about Devin's age but I did that for
privacy purposes this lesson Dev is 45.
ah
meanwhile every day you get online and
you lie about the fact that that woman
has a daughter that the woman that you
call your girl your wife has a daughter
and you're only are you lying about it
you write about the fact that your
girl's old which is fine but you lying
about it yeah while telling other people
to not wife up used Goods that's what
you you say
um Devin is my girlfriend she is not my
wife we have never been married she is
not a single mother and we do we have
not adopted anybody so you say that
during bankruptcy she lied about the
fact that this was her daughter she lied
to the government that she wants to
believe maybe maybe that she's
committing fraud maybe that's what it is
it's better it's better than to accept
that he's dating a single mother okay
yes I do what are you taking the
conjunction the fact that the niece
who's exactly the exact same age visits
twice a week
the circumstantial evidence don't look
good for you does it absolutely not okay
there are there are older women out here
older single moms who are out here out
competing younger childless women
so how would it listen I'm not saying
this would be easy but it is possible so
what would be your advice to your friend
well okay so does she have full custody
of this child or does she have shared
parental let's say she has a 50
50.50 then she's not a single mom
parenting okay okay
that makes sense because you're not a
single parent at that point no you're
definitely not you're no more single
than a single parent than if you are
still married do you see how he makes it
work
do you see how it makes it work they
made up their own definition of single
mom if we share custody did you see what
she did you did good oh I didn't do good
no no I know I know
I know that's not you that's not you Hey
listen I'm gonna just tell you this
right now it's not because your kid goes
to his dad's place two three times a
week that you're not a single mom this
is not an insult it just is what it is
you are a mother and you are single
that's what the definition is you've
only changed it
you guys are good you guys are good and
if I'm wrong I want all the red pill
fans to come in the comments saying am I
wrong about what I'm saying if a woman
says I ain't a single mother the day
she's with her dad three days a week
what you gonna say what you gonna say
Donovan Sharp
made a video recently talking about my
alleged wife
like they really try she really tried
and I'm gonna explain to you because I
haven't spoken about it and I'm
explaining to you what happened what
happened was this
one of the whole debacle with fresh and
fit happen they were trying to get some
juice to get at us and what happened on
my other Instagram page that got
canceled I got deleted right they went
to all
throughout all my pictures and they went
to see if they could find a picture of
my wife if you don't know anything about
me I don't post about what I got I'm
talking about where I live Vehicles
whatever what I don't post that I don't
put pictures I don't put pictures of my
people around me why because people on
the internet are [__] weirdos okay
they found a picture of someone and I'm
going cheeks to cheeks with that person
right or cheeks to cheeks and we're
blowing a kiss
and he took that picture and he said
that's his wife
got him it's not my wife no she's a
she's a comedian she's a comedian and
we've run a bunch of live shows and
she's participating she's part because
she is I have pictures with her he has
pictures with her like she's on a lot of
her bills unless you think priest
married a comedian I don't know but
that's my homie homie that is my homie
for real okay she is not my wife very
talented comedian very talented actress
in Quebec right where we live at but she
didn't know that they went on and they
ran with it and they call this person a
whole bunch of of things right a whole
bunch of names even if that person was
my wife
let's say she was my wife to go after
people's wives you have so little
arguments that should go you have to go
through people's wife but you're so dumb
that you don't even realize that's not
even though so you go out there and you
slander someone
that has no relations to me
that's you well Cassie would have the
world believe that she's always been
this doting dutiful well you know what
no so in this clip now he's talking
about another man and his wife who also
happened to be a single mother before he
got married to her and now he's talking
about this woman named Cassie who's that
single mother I want you to hear what he
says about her Cassie West has been ran
through Cassie West was a single mom
when she married David West Cassie West
Chase Bad Boys she's a Karen that was
ran through like everybody else was a
single mom and this explains why this is
this explains why David West is as weak
as he is but uh yeah David listen man um
I'm not trying to be mean spirited but
you married a single mom like that
doesn't make you a bad dude and Cassie
you being a single bomb when you marry
David that doesn't make you a bad person
either just understand that it's out
there and so you guys on this holier
than thou oh we did it the right way
Cassie let's not pretend that you didn't
take the typical route that most modern
women had taken David let's not pretend
that you're some Apex alpha male like
come on like we both know throwing
stones from glass houses you are here
criticizing him talking about he's not
an alpha apex predator what are you
pooped at least he admits whatever life
he's living to who cares you're the one
who's lying about the fact that she's a
niece you're the one who's lying about
your girl's age that's you who are not
even man enough to actually come into
the light with the woman that you're
with no matter where I'm at all right
whether it's uh in my house or in my
Airbnb one on my way or in Antarctica
or or even when I'm taking I need to
have access to all my programs hey
but sometimes the internet doesn't allow
me for that because it's restricted
because of the area that I'm in
yeah and for that I need a system that
allows me to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes in a
wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and it allows you to just change
the location of where you are and you
can watch everything that you want no
matter where you're at right now with
surf shark you can just use promo code
Abba and preach use promo code ever and
breach and you're gonna be able to have
83 off plus there's a plus
three months extra free I know crazy
get on it any man who marries a woman
past the age of 23 years old you're
getting leftovers Devin let me get you
into this conversation because I met you
when you were 32.
he said married again he's playing on
words he's married he's married to her
he's married they're just lying about
the records it's just it's sad that's
you in Japanese
to so many people that's [__] [__]
my guy
imposter to that image that you have to
lie about you spewing like hate and lies
to people just to sell an image you're a
sad sad human being I'm not even pissed
off no more let me be generous maybe
it's not his wife that's the girls that
you've been in a committed long-term
relationship for five to six years it
doesn't even change anything the person
you're choosing to make a long-term
commitment to is exactly what you
describe as a person not to get with to
everyone else as ran through and asked
they used Goods that's your girl that's
[__] that's how you talk about your girl
girls think it's cute and attractive to
brag about their
so we'll escapades but I waste zero time
in 304 shaming them I'll refer to Dev
dude when we first started dating she
used to brag about the dudes and she had
smashed straight up she used to brag
about him dude she used to brag all the
time
now at first I just told her okay stop
she didn't
hold up okay let me just say something I
don't know what's wrong with your life
brother and the women that you're with
but no woman comes to me to tell me
about all the dudes they've been ran
through by you gotta be some [__]
[__] pathetic ass who that they don't
respect you like that women are coming
to you like man I took the biggest if
women are saying that [__] to you you're
a [__] loser and they don't look at
you anything better than the scum off
their feet Nobody Does that bro I never
unless hold up guys that got guys in the
comments when you kick it with a girl
and she likes you have you ever heard
her start talking about the previous she
used to like to take but you realize
that a lot of these dudes who do this
red pill manosphere stuff a lot of them
are just cornballs who actually have
zero gaming zero ability to seduce women
now at first I just told her okay stop
she didn't and then I told her look stop
it
she did it one more time one more time
she tested me Hey listen one more time
no can we just appreciate again this man
established a boundary and said don't do
it and the girl had so little respect
for him she like man bro you need to
know about all the things I've taken
he's like no stop no no you have to
understand I was with this [__]
Behemoth stop that was it he wanted to
tell you
Peter can't even
place I got five foot white women
disrespected him to his face one more
time she tested me I assumed her
literally two tears you better believe
it I called dude I called her every name
in the book why would you want to have a
relationship with someone that should do
that to that's your girl I'm not I'm not
talking I'm not talking to him because
that's sad I'm talking to y'all people
out there okay if you have to resort
into shaming someone get the [__] out
the relationship you do not want to be
that person
and you don't want to be with someone
that you disrespect like that if the
person disrespects you and you
disrespect them and then you think
that's how you get out of there that's
that's not good you do that because you
can't get better
say it like it is I don't have to keep
nobody in line say that again say what
say that again shame her if you got
value you don't sit there having to yell
and scream at a one you don't have to
this is sad first off you've already
garnered enough respect that she never
goes that far but secondly if she's
acting out of pocket you'd be like
deuces
who's out that's it you think I would
sit there unless a woman say some crazy
stuff about my family my mom and then
push the envelope oh no you gone and she
knows which is why they never do that
around me again I'm also very respectful
and kind this is a mutual thing it's not
a one-way Street all right I know how to
act around ladies but they also know how
to act around me in that regards because
why there's mutual respect there you
don't have that because she don't really
see you as that much of a man that's the
only way you can tell me that she's
talking to you this crazy that's if this
story is even true but whatever I mean
why would you make up a story where your
girl's telling you all kinds of oh just
to prove it hey baby you're right cause
you've been lying about everything lying
about a bunch of [__] and just to say
his phone right here is just to show
people that I got to hold my girl yeah
you know I'm on top of that so he could
be lying because in his head it makes
him look a certain way but it doesn't
yeah so it might be a lot and that [__]
mine it might never happen what's the
number four
what's the number four to all you
loser fans of Destiny is this really the
guy you look to as something to Aspire
to
would you want your life to look more
like his or more like mine
let's do a comparison well listen now
he's smarter than I am number one he's
probably got more money than I do and
his wife is much younger and much hotter
than my girlfriend I'll give him that
I'll concede all of that those are
things about his life you know what's
weird about this whole thing why are you
looking at people's why my guy
like if this is your girl why are you
constantly out here downplaying her and
her looks why do you constantly feel the
need to be like [__] imagine being a
relationship with a guy or a girl and
the girl constantly goes out on podcasts
and she's like yeah my mind's fine but
he's not the biggest I ever had I've had
much bigger even if it's true like why
are you constantly going out there and
reinforcing that something that just
shows that you don't respect each other
Devin slept with a lot of guys gentlemen
Devin has a high body count you think I
don't know that my own girlfriend has
had sex with a lot of men you think that
I think I found some special snowflake
who does who declined parting through
her 20s even though she has a great body
give me a break guys I am well aware
that Devin's Notch count is a lot higher
than she will ever admit I am 237
certain that I am not the biggest ever
that that Devon's ever taken
and the way I is not the best she's ever
had she's had bigger and better than me
she hasn't told me this but I know I'm
almost positive Devin's had bigger
better than mine but if I ever found out
what one of these guys look like if I
ever found out that one of those guys
had a 12 inch you better believe I'm
gonna be [__] insecure you kidding me
I don't have a 12-inch dick
Devon said bigger dicks in her now I
gotta see what that looks like of course
it makes us insecure that's another
reason why men don't men of value don't
commit to women with high body counts
he says men of high value don't commit
to win with high body counts and yet he
committed to
and yet
it's because we know the more stocks
that have been in you
the more huge said it that have been in
you it's just mathematical if you've
been with Five Guys
okay all right we can deal with that if
you've been with 555 dude you've
probably now I can't have a burger as
the war hey man this man's really
thought about this [__] you could tell
like this is a deep insecurity I honest
with you I don't worry about stuff like
that one because I'm packing but two
mostly because like when I'm with a girl
I ain't worried about what the last dude
did not worried about the guy but like
who cares will she go with me we gonna
do our own thing together that's it I
don't need to know the whole history
that's sad the only reason you deeply
think about this is because you got a
big insecurity on the inside and you
don't got the skills to actually lay it
down because if you do a good job a girl
gonna be satisfied if a girl gives you
her heart she loves you and you take
care of her needs you don't got to be
worried about the previous man the only
reason you dealing with this is because
you ain't got it like that and so it's
always a deep insecurities inside of you
you're a client learn from the Plant
City Police Department that on September
8th 2003 Edwin Hopkins Jr had used his
father's social security number to rent
an apartment in Pinellas County Florida
your fine went to the apartment complex
and obtained a copy of Edwin Hopkins
Jr's rental application which includes
Edwin Hopkin Jr's signature and Edwin
Hopkins seniors social security number
you're a fine learned that Edwin Hopkins
Jr had defaulted on his rental payments
in the amount of eight thousand dollars
and eight cents
on June 16 2004 your fight spoke with
Edwin Hopkins senior who advised that
the outstanding balance showed up on his
credit report Edwin Hopkins senior does
wish to prosecute his son for the crime
of identity theft
you are fine learned that Edwin Hopkins
Jr obtained a Florida identification
card listing the above mentioned
apartment as his current address your
find has been unable to locate Edwin
Hopkins Jr
my dad the spineless the spineless beta
male he is does not have the heart to
step to his own son and say hey look son
I disagree with you this man defrauded
his own father he uses social insurance
and his stuff to get an apartment
defaulted on the apartment the debt went
to the dead and it went on a social
Bureau the dead press charged his
charges and they went after him in court
he's also faked bank checks he's done a
bunch of other different forms of Fraud
and so what you recognize that's what he
does
there's a history yeah
his criminal record says otherwise you
know what I'm saying that's what he does
that's a history but again a lot of
these dudes in the manosphere they lie
about their accomplishments they lie
about their resume and it makes sense
because you're trying to make money
embellishing a lot of these things is
how you're able to Garner the audience
because you're like I live this life
therefore you want to follow me but once
you appear behind the curtain you
recognize that these are just scammers
that's all it be it Derek Jackson or
this loser you recognize it's two sides
of the same coin they got an audience
they want to cater to and they got a
product they got to sell so they have a
lot they have to project in order to get
that money that's what this is it's all
game so you guys got to peep it to see
it and understand all these people that
are public personalities online don't
buy into any other personas if I expect
you guys to take what I say seriously
about how to run your relationships how
to train your woman how to vet women you
guys have to know that I practice what I
preach
you guys have to know that I actually do
the things and I live the life that I
tell you that I'm living
I can't expect you guys to pay 800 for a
woman's course if you don't see that I
know what I'm talking about